hoy vimos como la cápsula cruz dragón de
spacex se acopló con la estación
espacial internacional que implica esa
manera en términos científicos y que
interacción va a haber entre ambas
tripulaciones
el interés científicos por los
experimentos que suceden en la estación
espacial lo más notable es el haber
utilizado el cohete en la cápsula de esa
cosa es realmente emocionante porque
cambia la forma de llegar al espacio es
realmente una nueva forma de hacerlo y
es maravilloso lo lograron y mirando la
imagen de uno no puede decir o
emocionarse de ver a estas dos
tripulaciones abrazándose embarcar y
allá en el mundo de hoy pero que sí
cuéntanos muy rápidamente qué
interacción de interesados y placeres
durante esos seis meses de emisión van a
trabajar juntas
mira todos trabajan juntos pero cada uno
con misiones separadas cada individuo
cada persona tiene su rol y bien y cada
uno va realizando experimentos distintos
tiene sus horarios entonces el ente uno
no sé cómo decir si quieres hay
interacción o no la verdad es que si
todo en la estación espacial es
colectivo pero siempre con turnos y
roles separados no no van dos personas a
trabajar juntas en un mismo experimento
en el mismo momento les dije todo está
rotativo pues durante esta misión de
seis meses los astronautas desarrollarán
experimentos científicos de
microgravedad qué significa esto y para
qué sirve ese tipo de experimentos qué
conocimientos pueden aportar a la
ciencia entonces con esta tripulación y
este gran logro que se está teniendo hoy
la microgravedad es esencialmente cuán
duro no experimenta la gravedad sino
bajar en un ascensor sin alambres que
uno cuando salta en caída libre no
experimenta gravedad porque no se la
cabeza y los pies están cayendo con la
misma aceleración uno se da cuenta se
fija la gravedad en cambio del suelo el
suelo es quien te afirma en el espacio
entonces cuando estás en órbita
no en principio no se siente gravedad
pero si hay un poquito muy poquito que
se nota como que te tira un poco es un
lado por eso se llama microgravedad
de todas las cosas que se hacen en la
estación espacial todos los experimentos
biológicos o químicos de crecimiento de
cristales de formación de sólidos de
estructura de líquidos bajo
microgravedad son diría yo lo más
esencial porque es lo que lo que de
ninguna manera puede realizar en la
tierra entonces los experimentos de
micro gravedad son si uno tuviera que
escoger sólo una cosa son lo que le dan
la razón de ser a la estación espacial
y bueno para terminar muy rápidamente
cuéntenos de la tripulación ya estábamos
viendo algo de las condiciones en las
que van a abrir por supuesto sin
gravedad pero que otro tipo de
condiciones podemos resaltar durante los
próximos seis meses y qué consecuencias
podrían tener en esta misión para el
estado físico de los tripulantes
bueno hay que recordar que llegamos a
estación espacial durante desde los 70 y
esta estación espacial en particular se
comenzó a construir hace unos 20 años
entonces lleva a ha habido gente en el
espacio por períodos de meses hasta
pedidos de un par de años ahora en
períodos de seis meses es bastante
significativo la disminución de la masa
muscular sobre todo disminución de la
masa ósea entonces los astronautas
tienen durante su estadía un régimen que
incluye hacer deporte bajo condiciones
bien extrañas
sin gravedad que uno puede correrse en
gravedad bueno se las arreglan para
hacer ejercicio para disminuir los
efectos dañinos sobre la masa ósea de
masa muscular y eso ya se ha conocido
muy bien pero toda la el día a día es
muy difícil dormir como duermes tú qué
no estás flotando te fijas tienes que
como llamarte a una cámara todo
como comer cómo haces tus necesidades
todo eso es único pero ya sabemos cómo
hacerlo